-♪ (OMINOUS MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-(WIND WHISTLING)
ROGER PARSLOW: Lyra!
Lyra, can you hear me?
-Roger!
-ROGER: You have to help me.
Where are you?!
(WHISPERS) Roger.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
LORD ASRIEL: I am gathering
the greatest from every world.
Even the heavens above.
SPEAKER: The real war is coming.
LORD ASRIEL:
And I would risk everything
to ensure victory.
What are you willing to risk?
FATHER GOMEZ:
Father President,
the time is coming.
The child is with her mother.
CARDINAL MACPHAIL:
Bring them to me.
Dead or alive.
It will be an honor.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
WILL PARRY: The last thing
my dad asked me to do
was take the knife to Asriel.
LYRA SILVERTONGUE:
First, we need to go
to the land of the dead.
ROGER: Lyra!
LYRA: Roger!
WILL: You can't bring people
back from the dead.
LYRA: We have to try.
WILL:
And what if we don't come back?
Then we will have died
doing something important.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Asriel,
our daughter is in danger.
The Magisterium want her dead.
Do you know who they say she is?
SERAFINA PEKKALA:
If the prophecy is true,
she will achieve something
far beyond your rebellion.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
Do not fail her.
MARY MALONE: Something changed.
Everything was in balance,
but now the world is dying.
MRS. COULTER:
Our lives are entwined.
It hurts when we're apart.
(SCREAMS)
MARY: The greatest love...
is the one
that you can't live without.
The one that
you're prepared to die for.
We're in this together.
No turning back.
LORD ASRIEL: The Authority...
wants you to be afraid.
Well, the Authority
has no power over us.
Today, we... are free!
(CROWD CHEERING)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
-(IOREK BYRNISON ROARS)
-SERAFINA: Hope...
will spark...
in darkness.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪